Capcom Creator and the owner of the
sphere Hunter YouTube and twitch
channels
yeah awesome thanks for joining us we're
really excited for the Capcom Spotlight
today we're covering five titles today
that we've already announced so that is
Mega Man Battle Network Legacy
Collection uh ghostrick Phantom
detective Monster Hunter rise uh
exoprimal and Resident Evil 4.
um and just to set some expectations we
won't be announcing any other new titles
today but we're just covering some
updates for those titles that we've
already announced uh but you know we're
really excited to share some news on
those and there will be more chances for
us to share some news from Capcom
throughout the year so you know we just
want to always give you guys the updates
of the games that we're working on and
we're hoping that you guys will tune
into this Spotlight and to other
showcases and spotlights in the future
so let's start with the first game Mega
Man Battle Network Legacy Collection
um Kellen I know you've been working on
a ton of Mega Man games throughout your
careers yeah give us give us the rundown
on what we can expect yeah so Mega Man
Battle Network likes collection as the
name suggests it's a collection of 10
games uh ranging from the first game all
the way through the sixth game so that
includes the different variations
starting with uh starting with three uh
so basically you have the entire
storyline it is kind of like one unified
storyline across all six games all
brought together in a really nice
package that includes like some
additional features like online and
basically online net battling and Chip
trading as well
yeah Ruby Susie um have you guys had a
chance to play any of the games in the
Battle Network series not Battle Network
it'll be totally new to me but the
combat system is definitely interesting
yeah I've only ever played the classic X
and Legend Series so like Battle Network
it's always like been on the horizon for
me but I've never really gotten into it
so I'm actually excited to check it out
it's our chance yeah this is our chance
and it's all of them it's 10 games that
is so cool yeah I love that I feel like
there's so many Mega Man games in our in
collections at this point it's just yeah
yeah it's almost overwhelming there's a
lot of like easy ways to dive in right
um and you know just touching on it real
quick the battle system in this one is
really unique
um it's almost like a card based battle
system right
um you're basically sending battle trips
over to Mega man.exe uh basically you
know everything from canons bombs
basically things that can maybe shoot
straight forward
um you know bombs that kind of go
overhead
you can even actually like get the navi
information from other navies which are
like the little character basically the
kind of like your avatar in the virtual
world if you will
um basically use them and bring them
into battle as well so you're not only
moving around to this grid but you're
constantly thinking about how to how to
use your different battle chips to
basically kind of navigate battles
delete viruses and beat you know your
opponents so there's a lot of depth of
the combat and it's a lot of fun yeah I
like the strategy aspect of it a lot
yeah
uh next title go straight Phantom
detective just announced it last month
so um you know people don't have to wait
too long to play it
um Roomba you actually said that you
you've played this uh the game before I
did I played it for the first time last
year and it just it blew me away I loved
it from the get-go and I'm so excited
for more people to actually play it as
well
um yeah I just the entire time playing
it all the detective stuff the
animations the characters just where
have you all been my whole life
and I unfortunately have never played it
so yeah I'm definitely looking forward
to checking it out because yeah it's
always been a title that all my friends
have uh told me to play so I think
you'll love it yeah I think I will too
the animations look amazing so yeah I
mean your Chance is coming up so yes I
will take it yeah like it's it's a game
written by Shu takumi and so a lot of
people may already recognize that name
from the Ace Attorney series uh so he
was also the writer for go strike
Phantom detective
um so if you love Ace Attorney you're
not going to want to miss this uh really
fun engaging story really amazing
characters
um you know there's a really great
opportunity for you know this going from
kind of like a niche title do something
that's going to do a lot more platforms
it's a really great opportunity to jump
into it yeah and if you like Pomeranians
one's the main character that's true
yeah
missile the Pomeranian yeah yeah and now
I have to play it
uh let's jump over to exoprimal um game
we haven't seen for a little bit
um we did announce this back in 2022
um Kellen I know you've been working on
this game
um dinosaur action kind of says it all
it's just it's looking pretty awesome so
tell us yeah tell us a little bit more
about the game yeah so if you're not
familiar EXO prime it is a 5v5 team
based PVE and PVP shooter slash action
game there's lots of them back there but
I'll try to make it simple so basically
you're being thrown into these various
war games uh run by this the you know
kind of mad AI named Leviathan
you're constantly thrown in with other
players but the way it works is you're
constantly given New Missions each time
as a live and kind of gives you new new
strategies and things that you have to
enact so uh basically you're you're
working with these other players uh
trying to basically cut through and
fight through different hordes of
dinosaurs uh ultimately you know either
resulting in a head-to-head match with
another team at the very end to kind of
determine who's going to win or there
might be some other outcomes which we
saw in the uh previous closed beta test
or closed Network tests I should say
yeah be have you had a chance to to
check out X Primal at all I haven't yet
unfortunately yeah I haven't either but
you know I think it looks really fun so
it does yeah yeah it's a lot of
interesting stuff you can do like you
can also even switch suits uh mid game
so if you're not feeling your team
composition the suit that you're
currently using you can actually switch
these to kind of like pop out of your
current one you'll run around as a pilot
for a second but then you can actually
just summon in another one take on that
suit you're already in a new role so
you're never really leaving the action
yeah I love the sound of that because
there's so many other like multiplayer
hero shooters that don't allow you to do
that so when you like get wiped as a
like as a unit you can just you know you
don't have to wait for a whole new match
you can just do it on the spot
yeah I think Kellen um you know you said
it before if you if you like the kind of
action games that that Capcom makes
that's really it's it's right kind of in
there
um with some of the stuff that we made
in the past I mean even one of the EXO
suits I got uh very like Devil May Cry
Vibes I think there's a lot of Capcom
DNA in exoprival and that's what makes
me excited for it
um you know you mentioned the kind of
the the virtual suit as it was in The
Zephyr uh you see a lot of that feeling
from you know a lot of other Capcom
franchises across the seats yeah from
what I've seen so far it kind of reminds
me of like a Capcom greatest hits in
terms of mechanics yeah which is really
cool yeah
yeah moving on for exoprimo
um obviously I think the one that we're
all super super excited for Resident
Evil 4. speaking of greatest hits yeah
yeah I mean it's coming out in just a
few short weeks
um and you know we've shown quite a bit
at this point
um in our most recent trailer I think
there was just a ton in there there was
you know battling through the castle
with Luis and you're seeing him in
places that you haven't seen him in
there's a krauser fight there's just
tons of Crazy Action so you know tell us
tell us your reactions to the last time
yeah no the Luis is definitely the
biggest surprise in the last trailer
um and they get to hang out more and
actually develop this chemistry
um yeah yeah it's like not surprised to
see him it's just shocking to see like
Louise fight enemies that he never looks
at in the original you know like that
you just have to do by yourself but now
you have a pal you've got a buddy who's
really cool it's like I just I just want
to see that connection grow more because
it definitely felt a little more
mysterious than the original but I feel
like we're gonna get way more out of
that character yeah in particular
probably just everyone like I mean even
Ashley has like just so much more of a
expanded role this time around based on
what we've seen you know her and Leon
are very veiny looking yeah and a lot of
those cut scenes like actually feels
like they're gonna struggle to survive
this time and not really just a little
bit of information yeah yeah just a
little bit not just shake it off like
yeah whatever like
yeah I think that was one of the
questions with the when we first
revealed Resident Evil 4 of you know
it's got this really dark tone that you
expect from something like re2 and re3
but then is the action still there is
the atmosphere and and kind of like the
more goofy elements of Resident Evil 4
are still in there and it's all in there
yeah yeah
suplex crazy parodies roundhouse kicks
like just amazing and it just looks like
so much fun and it looks very replayable
too like I think there was um some
Stealth gameplay shown off like you know
or maybe hint to that with some of the
weapons and just actions that Leon can
take you know I saw him crouch in a
house one time and I was just like oh
wow you could probably you know approach
situations differently yeah like to
agree to a degree that you just couldn't
in the original yeah I mean in in terms
of those actions you know this will
people's already seen this by now by the
time they see this
but do we have the United Ferry as well
so there's a lot of things you can Parry
um we don't want to like we don't want
to spoil too much of that but uh Leon is
very I Parry a Del Lago is that only one
way to find out
you got a lot of like really cool fun
options to do with that so I think
people are gonna like have some real fun
with
with the new ways that you can use the
knife yeah okay we even kind of showed
off early right with the with the
basically countering the chainsaw like
yeah and it holds up his knife like
chainsaws yeah
um I am going to play this game for 10
years
yeah exactly
heard it here first yeah we'd be remiss
if we didn't talk about the krauser
fight oh yeah just being able to instead
of those qtes now you're actually
parrying in real time yes yes it's
rewarding you for all the parries that
you do earlier part of the game it's
actually train you for the Crosser fight
yeah I love this it's a genius designs
so kinetic and frantic aliens Leon's got
experience now right so yeah yes you can
do anything but even defaulters when
crowser attacks him
so I know you all are American just like
me
and I know you're a hunter
just like Monster Hunter that's right
that's so cool we're kicking it over to
a couple of trailers for just recently
uh recent titles so yeah yeah
countdown's still going
um yeah what we're seeing right now is
just the most recent update
um that we just released for Monster
Hunter rice sunbreak
um Bill Khanna which we revealed
um Kellen I know you're you're at Capcom
during the iceborn world era so
that was a big one yeah big fan of
velcana yeah I order my velcana like
jacket to work every day yeah yeah and
your your plumage hat yeah
yeah we've released a ton of updates for
uh for Sun Break so far
um so this was the fourth update and
we've got the fifth one coming in the
future so we're pretty excited about
that just just a ton of content and we
just keep adding like the most hardest
monsters possible and then people post
clips about how they got destroyed which
you know personally I laugh at every
time so keep sending them or how they
spent like tons of time learning how to
destroy it yeah yeah because you know
that's really cool too my favorite thing
so far is every time we release these
updates um like I see a new move from
some monster that like I've never seen
before and I'm just like
that's in there
yeah any surprises for Monster Hunter
yeah that's what's so cool about it
there's so much replayability you know
for every single fight in the game in
all of these games like every experience
is so unique to the player yeah hey
there's my hair
yeah we uh well it's coming up on screen
but we yeah these guys oh nice oh wow
that's so cute I do like these designs a
lot they're just so they're so over the
top yeah yeah I think there's an art
form and making something like very
detailed but like not at the same time
but that's actually what I love about
capcom's games is that like you guys are
so like okay with just being like here's
re2 but also 1999 in Persian you know
sorry 98 version this is a big block man
running around like
yeah and on screen we've got one more
update coming in in April so look for
for news on that uh in the near future
um but yeah yeah Monster Hunter
um there's just been so much content for
it people playing for hundreds of hours
um so I want to ask you guys like what
what is your most played Capcom game
I can tell you it's uh re one remake
that's also my favorite game just in
general so really I'd say between one
remake or two remake at this point yeah
how many hours would you estimate
so I would I would have to include like
back when it came out on GameCube with
like the HC version like probably just
thousands of hours yeah like it's my
favorite game so I definitely don't have
thousands of hours but quite a few yeah
I don't think I have thousands of hours
either it's okay I played it a lot but
not because
I think the first time I saw the
Resident Evil one remake I I was just
like Graphics can't get better than this
yeah oh yeah it's like it's impossible I
remember but when it first came out I
was like showing one of my friends and
he thought what I was playing was still
the cutscene
and I was like no I've been playing for
like 20 minutes yeah
first time I played I was just too
scared because it looked so real yeah
yeah I had nightmares about definitely
one and re4 which I mean in hindsight
maybe it's not as scary as I thought but
you know it's an intense game the
intro's intense yeah like you don't know
where you are
people are attacking you
um
so actually you know this coming to mind
now with Capcom arcade Stadium the
second Stadium
what's the earliest Capcom game was that
Sansan that was just on screen oh my God
I haven't played Batman in so long
um the the very first video game I ever
played was actually
um a Street Fighter 2 on uh SNES yeah
and uh I played as Cami and I fell in
love
right then and there but yeah that's
probably like the earliest um Capcom
game I played
I want to say eight no yeah I want to
say it's Street Fighter it was
definitely one of the earliest I I like
new Capcom games before I even knew what
Capcom was basically yeah like I always
see this logo as a campaign watch Capcom
yeah
I think it's Street Fighter 2 for me too
yeah yeah
that's classic
yeah I mean it might have been I was
like
real small kid it might have been ghosts
and goblins in an arcade once yeah yeah
like as an older machine
um but I still think that might have
been one of the earliest yeah actually
we're playing
forgotten worlds on the Genesis wow yeah
that was way back when for sure yeah
that might have been one of the earliest
ones for me honestly uh that mercs merch
is a big one I really liked yeah yeah I
thought that was like the first one I
played but it's I got fond memories yeah
so let me ask you guys logo reveals
Resident Evil 7 or Village which one was
more shocking seven seven
yeah you just it came out of nowhere and
it blew everyone's mind
yeah it just because like the game that
they show up before that is like so
different to what just everything that
we've played in re so it was like that's
Ari like what like that's Resident Evil
my favorite thing it's Max yeah and
there hadn't been like a Mainline game
in a in a hot minute so it was like it's
like five years really surprising yeah
because you just see the seven and
you're like I don't know what this game
is but it looks great yeah and then
Resident Evil By the time Village came
along it was kind of like we were
trained by seven so we were like this
could be seven was so right it could be
a Resident Evil game yeah
it's like the way it's it's like hidden
in the logo I'm like
yeah yeah
the even the Japanese version The
Biohazard uh the seven is in the Z
I love them both equally I've worked on
both campaigns so I can't I can't select
my favorite here yeah yeah
very understandable yeah I mean it's
great too because you just think you
know like how did they find the eight or
the yeah yeah it's just yeah
this is a perfect series of events it is
it unfolds for this game
for this beautiful beautiful game look
look how nice it looks oh my gosh
yeah you know what I I think I'm gonna I
think I'm gonna miss the winterses they
were they were they were fun they were
fun characters you know yeah I enjoyed
them yeah
anything can happen in this series that
is true yeah but yes I will miss them
too yeah got very attached to Ethan and
eight speaking of being attached you can
really be Ethan in Resident Evil Village
VR
but I think that is something I would
like to not be attached to yeah when I
see this I'm like um take that out of my
my cart
don't get too attached to his hands but
oh my God yeah I'll attached to this
headset
we are
not a fan not a fan
so curious
I just I love that I love jacket
inventory it's so cool yeah yeah and
just like everything is just so like
laser accurate and precise like yeah
actually being able to switch through
your weapons look at items everything
yeah you can do a really good job making
immersive yeah manual reload yeah so
tactile okay
[Laughter]
laughs
I didn't even I didn't even notice the
the cap flick yeah yeah
oh my God
totally yeah there's so much you can do
with this I've had had a chance to play
just a little bit of it
um I mean you're seeing most of it here
right like yeah dual wielding you got he
literally just threw the knife and just
throw the knife like I would love to do
that
yeah so before we we close out any any
closing comments
it looks amazing so far everything looks
amazing are you for a remake bring it on
let's go I think I speak for both of us
yes
yeah thanks so much for joining us thank
you
thank you we're super excited for the
the spotlight and um you know if you
want to pick up any of our our titles uh
the sales happening right now so uh go
ahead and do that and we'll see you in
the spotlight
[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to Capcom Spotlight where we'll
provide updates on our upcoming games
stay tuned until the end to hear the
latest on all of capcom's new titles
without any further delay here's the
first game
no matter what we're always connected
all 10 main light games in the Mega Man
Battle Network series are coming to
Nintendo switch PlayStation 4 and steam
Mega Man Battle Network Legacy
Collection launches April 14 2023.
Lan in his netnavy Mega man.exe work
together to solve countless cyber crimes
in the real world as well as the
interconnected online cyber world
a battleship to your chip folder to use
in combat as you battle viruses on the
net
[Music]
select multiple chips of the same type
and code each turn to create powerful
combinations
[Music]
receive getting a message from director
masakazu eguchi aka Mr famous
battle routine set execute
hello everyone it's Mr famous
I'm excited to share the latest Battle
Network news with you all
first check out this video
[Music]
thank you
Mega Man Battle Network Legacy
Collection includes all 499 patch cards
from Battle Network 4 onward that were
available only in Japan as physical
cards
in Battle Network 4 5 and 6 players can
enable or disable patch cards
Buster Max mode multiplies the
megabusters damage by 100 letting
players enjoy the story and speed up
combat
join this feature on or off at any time
during the story based on how you want
to play
and don't worry Buster Max mode is
automatically turned off for online net
battling that's all I have for you today
I've been Mr famous
thank you Mr famous
Mega Man Battle Network Legacy
Collection includes over 1 000
illustrations and 188 music tracks to
enjoy in the gallery
with online play players can connect
with distant friends and Rivals to trade
battleships and net battle too
pre-orders are available now Mega Man
Battle Network Legacy Collection brings
all 10 Mainland games to Nintendo switch
PlayStation 4 and steam
volume 1 and volume 2 will also be
available at launch
[Music]
starting March 21st the English version
of Mega Man NT Warrior will be available
to watch for free
check the official website for more
information
a new era of fighting games is upon us
[Music]
Street Fighter 6 launches June 2nd 2023.
this is the latest edition of the series
that redefined the genre
in addition to fighting ground where the
Pinnacle of genre defining battles take
place
Street Fighter 6 includes World Tour and
immersive single-player story mode and
battle Hub an online social space
reminiscent of arcades there are a
number of new ways to play Beyond just
fighting
today we'll introduce the final color
commentator included in the game
please enjoy this video
foreign
[Music]
let's get it
Japanese actress Hikaru Takahashi is
joining The Fray bringing our lineup of
play-by-play and color commentators to a
total of eight real-time commentary
matches the in-game action and brings
the competitive thrill and excitement
straight to your home
subtitles for real-time commentary will
be supported in 13 languages
turn on rally support and the
commentators will cheer you on
creating a more personal experience
[Music]
Street Fighter 6 Launches on PlayStation
5 PlayStation 4 Xbox series X and Xbox
series s and steam on June 2nd 2023
pre-orders are now available along with
a limited number of pre-order bonuses
see the official website for details
we'll have more Street Fighter 6 updates
at a later date
[Music]
com Pro Tour 2023 invites players around
the world to compete to the best
all right are you ready we're also proud
to announce the 2023 season will feature
Street Fighter 6.
to celebrate the game's release there
will be a special Prize Package this
season the first place winner of Capcom
cup will receive one million dollars the
total prize pool for the season will be
over 2 million dollars
next we'd like to share some exciting
Capcom news
Capcom celebrates its 40th anniversary
this June as part of the celebration
we're opening a digital theme park
called Capcom town
we're planning to construct a digital
Museum and other buildings
the grand opening is June 12 2023.
please see this link for the latest
welcome
[Music]
at Capcom ID account is required to play
Resident Evil reverse exopranal and use
the online features of Street Fighter 6.
[Music]
you can use this account with other
Capcom services and campaigns such as a
survey about today's Capcom Spotlight
we'll release more titles and services
compatible with Capcom ID soon register
now for Capcom ID
futuristic exosuits and dinosaurs class
in EXO primal
in this team-based action game players
suit up as EXO fighters who work for the
IBS Corporation
use a variety of unique EXO suits and
rigs to fit your play style and work
with teammates to combat hordes of
dinosaurs in Dino Survival let's take a
look at the latest trailer we have some
surprises in store so be sure to watch
to the end
in every war game Ace really is getting
called back three years into the past
back to 2040 right before the stradivada
fails
you're a time traveler
there's no random outbreak Leviathan is
intentionally summoning them as cannon
fodder for the war game but why why
repeat the same day over and over
three years ago
one of the first outbreaks
never found out more tonight
she is delighted
on the island
[Music]
in the past
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
okay you want to try talking to parents
are you another wall
hmm
still has some
oh
you're ready
another EXO fighter recruit right
welcome to ibius
foreign
what did you think we had a lot of new
info including the release date let's go
over it in detail
EXO Primal Launches on July 14th
before that we'll be holding an open
beta test
in addition to the eight EXO suits we've
previously introduced the two new suits
in today's trailer will also be playable
in the open beta test
experience the power of each exosuit for
yourself as your team faces off against
a wall of dinosaurs in Dino survival the
game's main mode
participants in the open beta test who
fill out a survey will also receive an
IBS metal charm that can be used in the
full game
please visit the official site for beta
test timing content and bonus item info
now I'd like to introduce the survival
pass reward system
[Music]
as players acquire experience points in
the survival pass their survival pass
level goes up and they earn rewards
separate from player and suit levels
the survival pass includes a free tier
and a paid premium tier
purchasing the premium tier unlocks
access to special rewards including 19
Exo Suit skins and 10 weapon skins
here are some of the rewards
the deluxe edition includes the survival
pass season 1 Premium tier as an added
limited time bonus
EXO Primal launches July 14 2023
pre-order bonuses are also available
please see the official site for details
on bonus items and the game
the latest EXO Primal news can be found
on the official website and social media
we'll have more for you soon
we look forward to seeing you in the
open beta test
use your powers of the Dead to uncover
the truth about your death
Ghost Trick the classic mystery game
from Ace Attorney Creator shu takumi is
being reborn
the game release on June 30th 2023
one knocked in the dark corner of the
city a man named Sizzle is shot and
killed
he reawakens as a soul and realizes he's
lost his memory and his life
who was I who killed me
why did I have to die
these are the Mysteries he's trying to
solve with the powers of the Dead
Sizzle has two basic abilities
possessing objects in the Ghost World
and then tricking them in the real world
a Hitman is after the red-headed Target
Lynn
use the powers of the Dead to get her
out of wild predicaments
the key to changing fate Is possessing
and tricking all sorts of objects
thistle will face death in many forms
use the powers of the Dead to go back
four minutes before someone's death
changing their fate will change the
story
and that story must be linked in some
way to the mystery of sissel's death
this port includes updated high-res
Graphics increased frame rate and an
optimized user interface
check out the new challenges feature
illustrations and music from the game by
meeting certain conditions
in addition all 37 tracks from the game
have newly arranged versions
foreign
you can switch between the original and
new versions as you play
[Music]
hello everyone I'm Shu takumi the writer
and director of the original Ghost Trick
game
we're thrilled to share the release date
with you all I'm incredibly excited to
revisit Ghost Trick we have yasu masal
kitakawa from the great Ace Attorney
series handle the music
he did incredible work remastering the
original songs to match the new graphics
we've also added original music from
composer masakazu sugimori to celebrate
the new version of the game I hope you
enjoy these new songs
the story of Lost lives and lost memory
all in a single night
Ghost Trick will be reborn in high
resolution with new music on June 30th
2023 for Nintendo switch PlayStation 4
Xbox One and steam
pre-orders are now available
check out the official website for
information about the pre-order bonus
please stay tuned
[Music]
it's time to awaken your hunting Spirit
on even more platforms
[Music]
Monster Hunter rise is now available for
Xbox series X and Xbox series s Xbox One
windows PlayStation 5 and PlayStation 4.
please watch this video with information
about the latest promotions
this is our Outpost Elgato
foreign
[Music]
good job
foreign
the massive expansion Monster Hunter
rise sunbreak will be released for these
platforms on April 28 2023
you can look forward to a host of new
features including new monsters locales
and combat mechanics in addition to
memorable new characters and story lines
the expansion includes the free title
updates up to free Title Update 3 giving
you instant access to chaotic gourmagala
and other powerful monsters
we'll have information about future
updates at a later date
[Music]
free title updates are also available
for monster hunter rise sunbreak for
Nintendo switch and steam
we will host a monster hunter rise Sun
Ray digital event in April to share the
latest information about the next free
title update 5.
[Music]
moving on to our next topic we have news
about the Resident Evil series
oh
[Music]
my God
Resident Evil death Island
foreign
we're excited to share this new preview
with you all you may have noticed Jill
Valentine made a brief appearance at the
end of the video
Resident Evil death Island will release
this summer
survival is just the beginning Resident
Evil 4 launches soon
[Music]
thank you hello everyone I'm yoshiyaki
hirabayashi producer of Resident Evil 4.
we're grateful for all of the re4 fans
who are excited for the game's release
this game is a remake of the original
which was released in 2005.
it takes place six years after the
Raccoon City incident and depicts
federal agent Leon S Kennedy as he
fights to survive
yes I don't know our goal is to create a
fresh yet familiar experience we've
preserved the core of the original game
and added updated graphics and a
reimagined storyline
re4's release date is just around the
corner but we have a special
announcement prepared for you today
please check out this video
ah here we go
these guys don't quit
no [__] way
are you gonna be kidding me
[Music]
the wait is over a trial version of
Resident Evil 4 that we are calling
chainsaw demo will be available starting
today
it takes place in the beginning of the
game as Leon first enters a European
Village the chainsaw demo has no time
limit and you can play it as many times
as you want the platform supported are
PlayStation 5 and Playstation 4 as well
as Xbox series X and Xbox series s and
steam we hope you enjoyed trying a
portion of this reimagined survival
horror
Resident Evil 4 is currently available
for pre-order
both the standard edition and the deluxe
edition include pre-order bonuses
sure to check them out
there's not long until the March 24th
release date please enjoy the trial
version until then
thank you for watching today
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and finally we have a message about the
Capcom publisher sale the Resident Evil
series with the exception of the
upcoming Resident Evil 4 and Monster
Hunter rise are currently on sale and we
will be opening the massive expansion
Monster Hunter ride Sun Break for
pre-orders
we missed this opportunity to pick up
digital copies of capcom's hits
foreign
that's all for our event today thanks
for watching
[Music]
we look forward to sharing more about
our latest titles through a future
Capcom Spotlight or Capcom showcase
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]